and we are lives
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here with a very special brother
bengali brother
brother hussain salam alaikum bro
upon whose testimony do you say the
realest podcast in the world
uh honestly the only testimony that
matters no i'm just playing
is based on our feedback bro and it's
unrefuted undisputed bro if you could do
better than do better show us someone
better
now a lot of requests have been going to
speak to brother dilly and bengali i
want to bro maybe we'll do for a little
bit but i don't want brother rami to
feel out of place you know
bengali he doesn't identify with the
bengali you know discourse anymore right
of course yeah yeah trent trans uh
so how was your journey bro from
bangladesh to palestine it was it was
rough it was rough but uh you know it's
easy to identify uh kind of against the
israeli people so that makes me feel you
know like one of them
okay bro i mean you guys are here first
brother dilly man you're in the uk right
now i'm indeed i'm indeed i'm the
born and bred or what's going on born
and bred in bedford my dad came in 1966
uh pretending to be the son of his uncle
that's how a lot of people came at the
time
he was six seven years old and we've
been in this town called bedford uh
which is only 40 miles north of london
born and bred never left the hood
[Music]
we were in fact in fact my dad my dad
may allah bless him and preserve him i
mean
he was the first immigrant child in
bedford town
really for me yeah so from indians
jamaicans
uh pakistanis bangladesh my dad was the
first immigrant child in bedford
wow yeah
so yeah so so deep roots in this town
deep roots in this town so you're you're
second generation then no we'd be
considered well it's debatable we'd be
considered third or fourth
third or fourth household
because the first generation would be
those who arrived in the 50s immediately
after post war past world war ii so
that's the first generation so that
would be
my father's uh paternal uncles my dad us
yeah that's first generation
um it is debatable whether my father
would fall into first or second
generation
third generation would be my brother my
older brother lots that's the people who
were born 1975 1980s onwards
and
then the third or fourth would be us so
somewhat millennials born in the
mid to late 80s early 90s so muslims
have been in the uk
back in terms of uh
the biggest uh ethnic group of muslims
in the uk are south asians right so
that's about so about 68
of all muslims in the uk are first and
foremost either pakistani
and when we say pakistani they're either
from azerbaijan kashmir or german
and then you get bangladeshis are the
second biggest group and they are 95
from silent
then you get then you get indian
gujaratis
so we make up seven out of ten muslims
and the rest is like turks arabs
uh west africans and everything in
between
okay okay so bengali's number two he
said
in terms of numbers yes numbers and you
said celebi's the major composition of
that practically most bangladesh
all right bro let me let me ask you a
question in bengali
included i
mean okay okay rami bro do you wanna
assume what we said bro
no bro i don't wanna guess i'm gonna
sound stupid
but i was just asking him if he has any
siblings bro yeah that was that was my
first guess though that was your first
guess yeah i know you're gonna say that
now
so brother you're saying let's go right
into the meat of the matter a lot of
people have been as muslims caught in
this i guess tug of war who do i support
russian ukraine right it's not an easy
of a decision innately to a lot of
people like let's say the israeli and
palestinian conflict right or the china
and
muslims right so where do you come into
this picture
this whole kind of like what side should
muslims take
the nato u.s west back to ukraine or
russia
so five pillars actually held a debate
just last week on this very subject and
we're gonna do a part two because
muslims seem to be very conflicted over
this even there's the awam which is the
lay people
then there is obviously states and
governments even muslim states and
governments of which there are 52
they're split over there's a u.n vote
today it was neither here or there there
was no major majority there yeah
now personally speaking
the only muslims who should
be in a position to take a side because
it directly affects them would be the
muslims of shishan and crimea and that
region
because
that conflict directly impacts them in a
real way
and then by extension it would then
affect the muslims of bosnia-herzegovina
because we know that if russia is
outright victorious in ukraine it will
embolden the serbian nationalist gofar
and then make them want to start another
genocide so for those muslims they may
have to take a side because it affects
them do you understand for us muslims
sitting
in the west or anywhere else in part of
the world do we need to take a side i
would respectfully say no
and i would add to that by those who
like citing salah
that the fact that the sahaba and the
process were rejoicing when the roman
byzantines were victorious over the
persians there's a very unique context
to this number one at that time neither
the persians nor the romans had
oppressed and occupied muslims
number two the loyalty or the support
for the romans was based on akida they
were
christians they were closer to us in
creed than the zoroastrians who the
pagans of makkah were backing so i've
seen a lot of people use this example it
doesn't count yeah
here we have
two states and let's say let's add to
this very ukraine is not
free or innocent of muslim blood they
sent the third biggest unit as part of
nato to iraq yeah let's not forget that
also only four five six years ago
president zelen zelensky
he tweeted basically backing israel
saying that israel is being bombarded by
missiles from azer something along those
lines right and there was a muslim
brother who tweeted him that many years
ago and said watch the ride when that
happens to your doorstep
lo and behold this come so no one is
innocent or free of muslim blood here
right so therefore why do we need to
there is no such thing as a lesser evil
when there is an option not to choose
any evil right
and the list of crimes the list of
crimes of both sides and their
supporters is quite frankly endless
if you allow me just a minute to quickly
just give our viewers and listeners an
insight into this russia was always
regarded as the arch enemy of the uthman
it was never britain and france it was
the russians who were seen in terms of
constant aggression right
and then we go into the brutal 45 to 50
years of communist rule under the
soviets and the satellite states in
central asia the caucasus and balkans
where islam was quite quite frankly
eradicated yeah from the public space
yeah then we've got what russia did in
chechnya what they would they back to
serves against the bosnians and the fact
that they have martyred
hundreds of thousands of muslims of
hashem
right so for so for all those
hussein loving
anti-imperialist muslims calm yourself
your wallet is to the muslims not to any
kind of anti-imperialism is not our fur
that is not our criteria
around me i love you to beat my brother
al-aqsa is close to our heart but we
similarly say to the palestinians and
those who back two-state solutions on
one party over the other
your when you secularize and nationalize
the cause that's not african sorrow yeah
no matter how bad the oppression is
that's not african afrikaan
so on that basis muslims who are not
directly impacted outside of that region
don't need to take a side and that's
what the west and america nato yani i'm
not going to sit here and give you guys
a list of things that they've done it's
just it's too long
so no one needs to take a side there is
no sight to take
watch back sit back kick back watch
what's going on and make dua make dua
for the oppressed of the innocent of
ukraine this is what we do we are on the
side of those who are oppressed and for
those who are victims of injustice it's
not it's it's not rocky science
so the fact that we've got chechens
under kadhirov
fighting tatars and chechens of ukraine
muslims fighting muslims now there's a
whole debate as to kadhirov's politics
his treachery of the mujahideen and how
he basically wiped them out so he can
cement his power
and then there's a there's so many but
the point of the matter is these are
baited men who are saying
before going into battle and they're
killing each other and do you guys know
that just yesterday
that the national security um
representative ukraine confirmed that
the special chechen unit that was sent
by pewter to assassinate zelensky was
wiped out do you know how they were
wiped out fsb informed ukraine that yeah
we're sending a chechen unit to work out
your president they want them up so what
about that for treachery do you
understand
when we ever when we ever realized that
neither of these states and powers are
our allies allah tells us in the quran
they are allies of one another so why do
you seek victory from them in fact any
viewers and listeners who are watching
tell me a time in islamic history tell
me a time in islamic history from the
time of the prophets
to now
when a non-muslim came to liberate
muslims in the manner in which we
understood liberation within our history
never
so why we continue to turn to them i get
it for respite for
short-term wins pr wins i get all of
that but in terms of liberation and
victory
without overtly saying it we know how
and when that will happen that's not
going to happen from u.n and nato on
this man no way
that was a really good answer because a
lot of people think by default i always
have to have a stance i always have to
pick a side and what you're saying is
for all these things that don't directly
affect us nor are they impacting our
lives nor are we the most learned in we
don't have to jump the gun we don't have
to pick a side immediately we can chill
out for a bit
so i want to give his input to and his
insight and then inshallah we can
backtrack and you can tell us where this
really started from the whole russian
and ukrainian conflict
subhan allah that was honestly a really
really brilliant answer alhamdulillah
and uh that's something i found myself
leaning towards since the beginning like
how do you really like it's one
non-muslim versus another non-muslim
like what can you really say about that
except for what you mentioned about
those who are oppressed and innocent
people uh that is essentially what islam
you know would would stand for in this
kind of situation but allah in my class
yesterday we were discussing the the you
know
islamic rule and all of that
i just want to mention it's
absolutely insane that we had a khilafah
a hundred years ago
a hundred years ago the muslims had a
philanthropist
the same system the prophet saw himself
started fourteen hundred years ago
continued for thirteen hundred years and
only collapsed about years ago people
kind of have this this this notion or
feeling that
you know
russia
britain america canada all these nations
were so powerful for like thousands of
years and bro they only got power maybe
a few hundred years ago and they've only
been really powerful for 100 or 200
years or so it's like the muslims were
in power so so long so now watching you
know them fight it's like
it's it's crazy subhanallah in my
opinion
has only been a superpower in that level
for 80 years and i want to just quickly
recite a a a
narrative story from which i'm sure many
of uh listeners and viewers will be
aware of during the battle of honduk
when the confederate arab state
pagan arab prize had gathered in united
and they had surrounded medina and the
conditions were very difficult it was
cold there was a shortage of food they
were under siege
right and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam gave the glad tidings to his
sahaba about the opening of persia and
wrong
who amongst the ranks of the muslims
amongst themselves they were saying look
muhammad we can barely go to relieve
ourselves uh without thinking he's given
his companions the black tidings of
persia and arum lo and behold within 20
years we had already taken those lands
so
and these and arguably arguably
i know that's like pre-modern times
right i get it but
one could argue there are four vaster
empires that have come and gone right
so that is the sun of allah some people
everyone has their time but
as a dre you should say after having the
last laugh it would be with the muslims
insha'allah yeah
i mean
uh so my contacts were acting up bro i
can't read the text so i'm gonna put
these comments up do you mind reading
them inshallah yeah brother hussain's uh
input yeah insha allah to be honest i
think the most angering issue right now
was the blatant racism openly being
shown in the media towards immigrants
africans and muslims yes we're going to
get into that insha allah inshaallah uh
thank you for the super chat may allah
destroy both countries escalated the
conflict made the allies both
sides and
i don't know if i want to read this
anymore
destruction
to our our chests and uh healing to our
heart
i think i mean
to that to the end
[Music]
there's like some some nerd bro and like
a google you know youtube uh you know
cubicle right now being like gotham you
know flagpole right now another super
chat if some preachers are to be
believed it would have uh to be said
that the companions were unjust and
merciless when they rejoice at the
victory of the romans over the persians
yeah that's what the brother
mentioned at the beginning actually
found allah and what i wanted to mention
not only you know could we see these
empires as being more vast but look at
the muslims bro
what were the most compared to them
what was the muslim empire at the time
compared to rome and in persia
these like they why why were they not
conquered because they were in the
middle of the desert because they were
sheepherding bedouin arabs that people
didn't care about because they were
tribalistic so when they showed up at
their doorstep like yo what's up it's
like what the heck is this and then they
lost and then the muslims beat them and
then gained that power allah so like i
heard one comparison it's like it's like
the eskimos
defeating russia in america today
literally because the arab the pagan
arabs that time was seen as degenerate
backward regressive you know tribalistic
uh insignificant a land that was bound
in desert that wasn't worthy of kind of
even concrete we just left it the
persian romans had their beef and hashem
and they just allowed like arabia it was
like
right and
emerged emerged from this land in the
space of 10 to 15 years
a force that has
will keep its print in mankind from now
until the day judgment as such and such
such as our history brothers such as our
history and such as the lessons that we
take from the various times that we too
have tasted defeat
14th century so there's lessons to be
taken either way we can glorify our
history because there's a lot to glorify
it about but there's also
lessons to take from our history as well
yeah um
yes 100 it's not easy to understand
you'd have to go back seven plus years
to understand what is happening between
the two countries
it's not easy to say one is better than
the other unfortunately yeah 100 it's
like we're not it's not like like the
brother mentioned like palestine and
israel it's it's like two non-muslim
countries how can you really say you
know one of the other when they both
committed horrible atrocities in their
entire existence and one thing i want to
mention is we we mentioned like the
eskimos right conquering russia and
america and how crazy that would be we
compared the muslims at the time the
process of sentiment the sahaba
and
they were seen as like you said you know
tribalistic and backwards and you know
all these you know vile terms
i find it crazy that's kind of that's
how people see uh the leaders of
afghanistan right now
that's why you see them right now that
they're just you know backwards and all
this stuff so subhanallah i remember
there being a hadith i don't know if
it's authentic or not so if you know it
is or isn't please you know either of
you let me know but i remember hadith
talking about that there will come black
flags from
which basically afghanistan um who fight
with imam mahdi and like along his side
and everything
afghanistan
yeah so there's two narrations of the
black flags and the warm and the three
there's one about the black flags coming
from uh
historically speaking is not the quran
in iran it's modern day iran all the way
stretching through central asia into
afghanistan then there's another hadith
about the warm air of revival coming
from him now that's modern day pakistan
bangladesh india and also north
afghanistan
so there's various hadith pertaining to
that region and inshallah revival coming
from that region that
have said
have these prophecies been fulfilled
already because the abbasids their flags
were black and they emerged from that
land we had the delhi sultanate and the
mughals had already conveyed the message
of islam and had taken it there um but i
am of the more of the position naturally
because we're south asians that
obviously we still got you know the end
times might be coming from those those
areas under our under our leadership
yeah yeah
this is going to be the last one that we
read before uh brother hussain goes in
there is no moral side in this war the
only consideration is practically or
practicality
pragmatically this is the end of the
mckinder containment
of the eurasian heartland it is
comprehensively failed
what
[Music]
the united states
remains the only superpower that is able
to set the the rules of the game
yeah and this is an analogy that i use
all the time when i give talks islamic
societies at universities and msas for
those of you who struggle to understand
the multi-complexities
of global politics let me break it down
for you in the most realist terms
yeah we've all been to school lads yeah
all of us have been schools and we've
been in playgrounds and playgrounds
always have top boys
the top boy could be the one that's
popular with the girls the top one could
be the one that's the most best at
sports the top one could be the one
that's the most physically the strongest
the top where it could be the bully the
top boy could be the one
who generally
is clever smart uh but the same the
point is we have top boys in playgrounds
you sound like you describe in america
bro yeah the point i'm
going to say is there were five victors
to world war two
america britain france china and the uk
after they defeated the nazi and the
japanese they were then literally they
were known as the policemen of the of
the world right that's why they are the
permanent security members of the u.n
nothing happens in this country and in
the world in terms of all the other
nation states that are that exist
without the tacit direct or indirect
approval
of these said states yeah america
obviously emerged as the biggest of the
four right and they essentially set the
rules of the game of global politics
because the entire global economy and
the capitalist modern is pinned on the
dollar yeah now
given that situation
what's happening in ukraine and russia
at the moment
it does bring into question the balance
of power can things shift
and there is a conversation to be had
about what does that mean
for muslim countries who can play one
superpower against the other
because if we have a marketplace of
superpowers offering the developing
world of global south of the muslim
world wherever you want to word it
you've got competing superpowers who are
at war with each other who are
sanctioning each other and they're
essentially weakening each other it
actually favors the developing countries
because there's a market now there's a
it's not america ronda shonen set the
rules of the game is now competing so
when they're busying themselves in this
manner it does create an atmosphere or
an environment at the very least
at the very least a conversation a
glimpse of a vision of what the world
may look like when usa is not the top
boy of the playground
so
that that is a conversation to be had
and
turkey especially
turkey especially due to its location
due to its history in the region due to
its somewhat control of the bosworth
is in position to perhaps lose or gain
significantly from this conflict
100 100
do you want to backtrack and give also
in a glimpse or in a nutshell the whole
ukrainian and russian conflict and nato
and the treaties of the us is broken and
all that
i mean just to just i mean for those of
you who have not done like european
history or cold war history
in short
when the ussr
emerged it had various satellite states
right which was part of its
empire right it had communist regimes in
these countries and essentially it was
entirely
subservient uh to the ussr the soviet
russians and essentially their foreign
policy was in in alignment with what
russia and the ussr would say
um and it created they acted as a buffer
so all the central asian countries the
balkan countries ukraine and other
eastern european countries all these
countries acted as a buffer
as a protection zone political and
military for
soviet russia against the west yeah
nato the north atlantic treaty
organization was formed created led by
the us and britain and others to combat
and to prevent the spread of communism
all right now when communist russia fell
in 1989 under the under the leadership
of gorbachev right and then of course we
know that the mujahideen were victorious
against them in afghanistan
that obviously now
put russia in a position where it was
once he saw itself as a global
superpower with the ideology of
communism and ever since then the
arrival of putin he wants to relive and
and recreate
that kind of network of influence he
foresees that kind of traditional uh
style of russian empire hood
and that is what he's trying to
establish
on the flip side he would argue though
nato over the last 10 years has inc has
increased its military presence
in its border in his border countries
latvia poland and other countries and
now there were conversations about
ukraine
uh having you know warming or new or
having a neutral position towards nato
now ukrainians have immense and you know
uh similarities to russian particularly
culturally religiously
linguistically there's a lot of
similarity russia essentially sees
ukraine as part of its own country right
um
as a part unlike other issues so for
example russia would not see central
asian countries as part of its own why
because they're mainly muslim and they
all look different they eat different
they follow a different religion but
with ukraine
it see it literally sees it as part of
russia right and it has moved into
russia and obviously crimea 2014 and my
colleague russia muhammad sally went out
there
and he said that basically look these
guys first of all stalin wiped out about
quarter of a million muslims from crimea
wiped them out
killed them wiped them out yeah
uh ethnically cleansed crimea of tatar
muslims yeah
and then and then basically it always
saw ukraine as part of its part of his
body and limbs so now when nato is
buffering his presence up in neighboring
countries if what you know what beauty
must have thought you know what i can't
risk this and i've come way too close to
home i'm moving in but at the same time
putin has smelt weakness he saw the way
america pulled out of afghanistan he's
seen that
populist politics is on the rise in
europe there's brexit and there's all
kinds of other madness happening in
europe this is a prime time to move in
and this has always been the sunnah of
russia by the way
for centuries russia has always seen it
has always been seen by its fellow
european counterparts as a as a bit of
an insenic meek yeah meaning it's not
modernized itself to kind of compete and
liken itself to western europeans
because if you think about it the tsar
of russia was related to the royal
family of britain who were related to
the royal family of germany they come
from one clan so the point here is that
russia has always been seen as a bit
different a bit booky a bit a bit
old-fashioned you know what i mean yeah
and there's not much there's not much
foreplay in their foreign policy there's
no they'll just come in and let's do
what they need to do
there's no divide and rule there's no
warning shots russia just comes in and
does what it does but it chooses its
moments sometimes it's paid off
sometimes it hasn't and that's the way
of russia that's what there's always a
saying in um
european politics and the discourse of
your political european politics is you
don't poke the russian bear when you
poke the russian bear and he moves it
can work in his favor but he'll mush up
europe as well and historically we've
seen those two things so in short in
short
nato led and created by the us and other
western powers were created after world
war ii to combat the spread of communist
russia right
when communist russia fell in the late
80s in 1990 1991 the last battle was
obviously in afghanistan
russia always had an idea look similarly
the muslim don't we have aspirations we
were people who had a civilization we
are a people who had vast empires and
lands in control and we had it longer
than the russians and we aspire for it
do we not we pray for it we work prince
and actually the russians and the
performers are different so russia
always had this they saw themselves and
they positioned themselves as those as
in leaders of europe and when nato was
slowly slowly slowly moving closer to
his borders um you know turkey has the
u.s military bases with nuclear warheads
poland has it latvia's not got warheads
but it's got natural presence it's like
nah man i can't allow this i need to now
move in now that's the argument
presented by russia the other argument
is that no
we've always said that ukraine can never
be a part of nato it could be neutral
but it can never be a part of nato and
eu membership was never a real
discussion until now so in a crux
that's the argument at face value but i
think there's always a lot more to play
at hand for example russia is the
biggest supply of natural gas in europe
and countries like germany and italy and
others are huge recipients right um many
western european countries secretly buy
russian artillery and weapons yeah
so there's a lot there's a lot of play
here right and uh and i believe we can
never conclusively choose one analysis
over the other
because even the information that we're
being fed from either side and let's be
honest we're not in the west we're not
really hearing or getting much of the
russian side
but the war information is never
accurate there'll be things that will
come out in the next five 10 15 20 years
but uh okay so that's what it's about
that's the story in balamuri
man that was very comprehensive we got
two questions that are humming bro if
you want to address
so long as the muslim world has the will
a
a super union is entirely possible we
need to actively desire and work for it
so that we don't become playthings
of
eurasia and the atlantic's
brother jay perez is
becoming a member he says does dilly
have any recommended books or other
resources for genuine info on this
situation and history overall that
involve muslims any essential readings
muslims should have their or have on
their shelter
there's various books
that i can suggest but there's just too
many to mention maybe after the show i
can send you a list you're not
composting the comments listening
inshallah okay sounds good last one
russia is entirely paranoid since the
road to moscow so it'll be flat without
and without
geographical barriers so they have
always had a mass invasion from the west
every 100 years
or attempted invasions we we forget we
forget that
russia
was essentially the reason why adolf
hitler and the nazis were defeated in
world war ii when they had the standoff
in stalingrad and and made
the mistake of trying to fight russians
in the winter
uh
it was it was basically stalling on
russia that battered them and then it
was the red army that walked into
uh berlin and and basically waved the
flag of the allied forces so irony man
subhanallah look there's i forgot which
verse it was there's a there's a verse
that i posted i forgot subhanallah allah
actually tells us that when they're not
fighting us you know when they're not
fighting the muslims yeah they're
actually disunited amongst themselves
and that disunity is severe
and allah actually concludes by saying
because these are people who have no
hope so when they're not fighting us
they're fighting each other europe's
history is a bloody one
it is a bloody history
like like yes the muslim world in the
muslim majority world wasn't perfect but
we did not have the type of wars and
bloodshed that the europeans had and
that's coming from the from the split of
the roman empire right through to the
medieval kingdoms right think about this
for a moment yeah think about this for a
moment
the pope uh
pope urban makes an announcement for the
european kingdoms to make uh you know uh
religious war towards the holy land yeah
1096. he said the savages the barbarians
the turks the saracens they've all
ravaged the holy land and and our
christian brethren need your help
what did these men do when they started
going towards the mediterranean and
they slaughtered and pillaged and
ravaged uh their fellow christian lands
yeah these are people quite frankly when
it comes to warfare
they're bloody it's a bloody history
lest we forget world war one and world
war ii were not religious wars there
were secular wars led by
christian uh western white european
countries yeah millions upon millions of
deaths was never under the war or banner
of religion let alone islam so people
can say what they want to say when you
give them the historical facts they
don't like it the part of the matter is
that europe has a bloody history it's
actually genetically within them for
some reason or another to always fight
kill and pillage governments regimes i'm
not saying the people they are good
people there are good people amongst all
people just like there are bad people
amongst the muslims but for some reason
when europeans get into power right
they're always looking to mark each
other off they'll mark the muslims
[Music]
that's a great point
they have been very hypocritical so
after this inshallah we'll go into that
europeans have always viewed russia as
the other and will continue to do so
they will never thus be unified this is
also why the white nationalist
pan-european pursue is a forest forest
is debatable
it's debatable because at the end of the
day they're allied in two world wars
britain and france had no problem
aligned with russia had not been for the
bolshevik revolution russia would have
remained in the alliance and would have
would have seen through the end of the
first world war they allied again in
world war ii against the nazis so
no it would be a lie that they're
incapable of allowing one another they
have a lot more in common than they do
with muslims and non-christians and
non-whites so there's a lot more for
them to unify upon but it goes back to
that point that i made earlier yes
western europe sees russia there's a bit
like a weirdo like a muscular weirdo
yeah like like you've not kind of like
modernized and just just got with the
program you understand and and and see
the manner of
diplomacy colonialism as something
that's dated problematic not
representative of the european way and
the european way is of course if you
look at the style of colonialism
specifically speaking britain the
country where i was born in and also
colonize our lands for young is that
there the britain britain was never
about brutality first britain was always
about divide and rule let us find an
agent or a chum jar to to to oppress on
our behalf
yeah france
their sunnah was this
warning one
warning two
warning three we're gonna wipe you all
out that's how france works yeah
russia obviously i've already mentioned
there's no foreplay in their foreign
policy they'll just come and kill you
they'll wipe you out
so so and and and western europeans
still find that uh problematic and of
course there's the ideological
differences uh that exist from the cold
war
very well said mashallah very well said
and and it they'll never fully be united
unless they you know are one will want
to wear so long as they're in different
nations with their own personal uh you
know hundreds and for us they will
always have disagreements because
everyone's you know i don't want to
relate it to this verse but the verse
that comes to mind is when allah
mentioned have there been gods with
allah they each would have tried to you
know outstrip the other it's kind of
like that with nations as long as
there's other nations all the powers
they're each going to try and get on top
it's very very uh you know unique to
humans to be like that um now you
mentioned before that
it's basically very hypocritical
uh of europe to shed all this blood and
you know and cause all these wars
and not really look at it as it in the
same like they look at like you know
muslims when they've gone to war and
things like that another thing i find
very hypocritical is the news reporters
when they say it isn't afghanistan this
isn't you know powerful this isn't a
rapper iran that is completely in
shambles third world developing country
this is europe these are white people
these are christians as if europe wasn't
completely regressed and went through
the the dark ages
you know i would say not too long ago
yeah well you know what it is bro yeah i
wouldn't have a problem if you know
because let's look at the media outlets
that have been doing these reports yeah
bbc
sky news
nbc itv al jazeera
yeah
now if these media outlets
were
that they they identified and made it
public that we are a christian media
outlet
yeah or a white ethnic race-centric
outlet that kind of punditry makes sense
let me give you an example five pillars
the news organization that i founded in
2013 with my colleague roshan saleh if
we went and did a report somewhere we
will come from a muslim angle
unashamedly because we've already made
it clear we are a muslim news website
our news and our current affairs and our
analysis is seen from the prison and
framework of islam and muslims so that
would make sense yeah but these laws
claim to be secular liberal
uh non-partisan impartial
but then they're talking like why it's
this christian this blonde hair blue
eyes
so it doesn't make sense so that's the
problem number one if these were
christian outlets it makes sense if
there were white supremacist outlets it
would make sense but since they're not
they're mainstream media outlets are not
supposed to take positions like these
theoretically they're not supposed to
take positions like these yet their true
colors are coming out but look i will
say this
anyone who believes that the europeans
white european non-muslims wouldn't
sympathize with the ukrainians and that
they would sympathize that they should
or could sympathize with muslims equally
you're deluded our issue is not that
they sympathize with them more than the
muslims in the same way that the muslim
will sympathize more with the muslims
and the non-muslims but there's but
there's a very important context here
yeah
muslim countries
don't galavan around the world
waging wars and championing freedom and
equality and democracy for all creating
refugees creating the destabilization
the wars the sanctions
and the destabilization to then turn
around and say now you can't come to our
countries
namely a muslim country who does that
there's not a single muslim country from
the 50 weak measly embarrassing states
none of them do that none of them go to
other parts of the world claim to
present a particular world view kill
pillage and rape and loot in that name
create refugees and then say no you
can't come
and before we have any racist gammons
and karen's commenting if they do let me
say something to you the biggest
recipients of muslim refugees are muslim
countries lebanon turkey jordan
bangladesh pakistan the biggest
recipients of muslim refugees of those
countries no don't ever let anyone say
to you oh why don't they go to saudi
then no
muslim countries are already taking
muslim refugees in their millions romney
palestinians
lebanon
the syrians where are they they're in
turkey in lebanon i've just got back
from the bakar valley i've seen the
palestinian refugee accounts we have um
subhanallah
refugee camp in syria so don't let any
non-muslim commentators say well why
don't you go to your own countries first
and foremost we are going to go our
neighboring countries and they are
taking us in
number two
europe calls the walls directly or
indirectly you contribute towards the
walls in these lands that have made them
destitute and they rock up on your
doorstep and you treat them like animals
see that's the problem that muslims have
and we should highlight our problem is
not that you favor them and you treat
them better than or you sympathize with
them all
that's not the issue here and it
shouldn't be the issue is that you claim
to be equal you claim to be consistent
and you wage wars in our lands and then
tell us
now we don't want to take them in
do you know someone trying to say that's
the problem the problem isn't that they
favor them or they like them more than
the muslims it's their income
inconsistency and the mistreatment after
causing the wars in those lands and
creating the refugees to then now say we
don't want them yeah so
that's that's how it has to be seen and
just on that point about the media
coverage
the media coverage is the media coverage
if the bbc said that we're a christian
european uh um uh media outlet that kind
of commentary makes sense if the nba if
the nbc said that yes we're a a a white
supremacist or white focus white centric
or wasp centric whatever you want to
call it that kind of punditry makes
sense but these are not supposed to be
impartial this must be non-partisan
you can't use that like that punditry is
crazy and that is your true colors
coming down so say it loud and clear
say it loud and clear we don't want
muslims in our countries we want to go
to your countries to rape kingdom wage
wars and take your resources but once we
create we don't want you in our
countries say it say be open we can
accept brutal honesty and we already
know that what's in your hearts is
already worse than what we already know
so so that's the position we take any
muslim out there that thinks they should
treat us the same or that they should
sympathize with the same you're deluded
they're not because human beings don't
human beings gravitate
towards those who look like them eat
like them pray like them speak like them
worship like themselves that's normal
the issue here is the lies the
inconsistent the hypocrisy that's the
issue here and that's the point we need
to continuously highlight
our point isn't that you guys are
favoring the ukrainians you're
sympathizing your your
your tears are shedding because i know
our issue is what you claim and what you
do and then what you don't that's the
problem
very beautifully said uh unfortunately i
do have to balance i will i wish i could
say and you know speak to you guys about
this more
learn more you know on the live but i'll
watch you guys insha allah after i lost
and say that's honestly the probably the
worst part because they they essentially
what they do is they create an enemy
they go and fight that enemy and they
benefit from fighting that fake enemy
that they created
and then they come back as if they're
the heroes to have basically this
narrative that you are secular you are
so fair you are so just um while not
being fair or just is the perfect thing
that they they you know they need to
you know foresee these plans of romney
before you go rob yeah it was an
absolute pleasure to meet you my brother
i'm sure this is the first of many
meetings to come but listen to this one
quick one
there's all of a sudden lots of talks
now in british media about sending in
the mujahideen
oh okay so also so it's convenient now
you don't want to send them
when it's cannon fodder and it suits
your knees there's one caller that
actually rang in lbc radio and said send
the pakis in
send the packing with you
so we can unfold a man but cannon fodder
my forefathers who fought for the
british empire allah forgive them may
allah forgive them for whatever reasons
they decide to fight for them but the
point here is we are seen as cannon
fodder in the same way the maghrebis
fought for the french
absolutely
bro never thought of it in that
perspective
that's why they were muslims who did
mutiny against the british the mutiny of
singapore the mutiny of baghdad when
when when
indian muslims refused bro the british
the british empire developed one never
used to tell the indian muslim they
should come up against the ottomans do
you know that until man rocked up in the
battlefield like raw they're not making
like who these are oh god is the ottoman
and they should be mutiny bro their men
were killed
so the point trying to make is we've all
we always ever have been cannon fodder
we always ever have been coming fodder
from a colonial empire point of view and
and the same is happening with the
chechens who are fighting for russia and
sadly the same is happening for those
chechen brothers and tata muslims who
are fighting for ukraine but i will
respectfully say that the tatars the
tatar muslims and they
have more of a basis to defend their
lands than khadirov's people going and
fighting under the ban of russia
[Music]
we'll see you tomorrow at 7 00 p.m for
anyone that doesn't know tomorrow we are
reacting to uh the debate between
muhammad hijab and ayan hirsi so stay
tuned for that insha allah i'll see you
tomorrow
all right may allah bless you both
have you honestly bro it's been an honor
and a pleasure i wish you could stay
longer and learn more from them uh
insha'allah we'll do this again very
soon
man subhanallah
i want to take a quick pause right now
this might be an off-handed question
but you can give your thoughts on this
insha allah if you want so
a few years ago when i was new to the
dallas scene this is where i found you
right
it was the talk that you had on good
morning britain with piers morgan
and you were
on
i want to say shamelessly but i feel
that's a that's a bad word but you were
ruthlessly you were unapologetically
i guess pushing the needle forward for
what we believe in and what we stand for
when it comes to you know the alphabet
people in schools and all this in terms
of education
now
i understand at that time
what he was saying was he was
somewhat opposing your views
right and that video you know went viral
and i find that the issue with
liberalism liberal secularism and with
the media is they don't have
one instruction manual they don't have
divine revelation they don't have
objective truth
because his point completely changed in
a recent i say recent but it was after
that in uh in a debate he was having
with someone
and she was saying that trans women so
biological men
can participate in sports and it would
be equal and he was saying this is
absolutely true and i think the issue
with with liberal secularism and media
is they don't have one objective stance
they're always willy-nilly they're
always changing by the tune of of you
know the the current you know status quo
and the norms so what are your thoughts
on that
um so just to comment on the ps morgan
and good morning britain show um
that interview was the first time
that i appeared in the mainstream media
and i've appeared on various shows
primetime shows many times
american and and
british and global but that was the
first time
where i was asked
by the parents who are protesting
in birmingham
to go and speak and represent on their
behalf there were a group of parents
that said look we feel that brother did
you hussein on five pillars since
they've supported us from a media point
of view whilst we've been getting
witch-hunted and labeled and and and you
know made to look like biggest and and
homophobes we would like five pillars
that brother dilly hussain to go and
speak on the show on our behalf
so that put a lot of pressure on me
see i felt that my contribution and my
engagement with pierce morgan
and mike wilkinson the other shaytan um
was quite
relaxed it wasn't my normal self and the
reason why and the reason why i had to
do that was because i was not
representing five pillars i was
representing the parents
and the parents said to me
you just need to convey three things
please do not prosolitize that alphabet
ideology to our children if you're gonna
teach them anything you need to consult
us
number three
in the same way that the alphabet people
are a protected group under a particular
piece of legislation so are religious
groups so those were the three points
that i had to make it wasn't about
debating and having it out and because i
was there to make those three points on
behalf of the parents now
as you saw
it literally became 3v1 right with
pierce morgan getting very excited even
at one point in town and said do those
parents think that it's islamabad i
looked at him and i said what makes you
think i said to him
i said what makes you think why did you
say islam about for peace as if it's
just a pakistani problem did you not see
the jews and the christians also
protesting with the muslims he got stuck
and i also have to say this as well
that entire debate was 16 minutes 23
seconds
but the but the version they uploaded
onto youtube was 10 minutes they cut six
minutes all my shots to ps morgan were
taken out
and they posted that and every time we
try uploading the original version
there'd be a copyright infringement get
taken down so the full 16 minute 23
second debate is on the five pillars
facebook page because we can't upload it
onto youtube but they uploaded a 10
minute version by making pierce look
good and they took out all my stings and
my shots that's fine when they lose the
battle of ideas this is what they resort
to it's not a problem yeah
now with regards to objective morality
and objective truth
i i'm not surprised because when they
had a christian lesbian vicar or
represented from the christian faith
right pierce morgan was relaxed he
actually engaged with her quite
respectfully she wasn't
no no sorry correction not a lesbian
they had a christian female christian
vicar who was presenting the same
position as me
which is that look you know this is a
normative position within abrahamic
traditions there does need to be
consultation with parents that's the
fair and right thing to do at the same
time we do need to make a distinction
between hate speech and uh genuine
concerns of religious communities
not saying anything different to me oh
he was so nice and soft to her he was so
generous i'm trying to say so there's
always a different role for muslims that
are brown yeah even when you have a
white christian who will say the same
thing to you let me give you another
example brothers and sisters you can
google dili hussain debase dr osama
hassan from the quillian foundation this
was a debate from 2015 when we spoke
about should we glorify british history
in light of the dresden bombing under
winston churchill so i came on and i
said look i'm a bengali heritage
he did the bengali family where 3
million people died
yeah by by uh not by chance it was
something that was orchestrated yeah by
churchill three million is a
conservative estimate of the bengalis
that died as a result of the of the
famine yeah which mr churchill did how
can you expect me to sit here and praise
this man and say that he should be
champion as well as his his racist uh
job you know you know describing indians
as dogs and these kind of things bro
they all the presenter and there's a
right-wing commentator
called james dellingpole who went to
oxford university with with david
cameron the prime minister at the time
he was obviously coming at me there was
a
uh there was a professor kate williams
from the oxford university who's like a
left-leaning kind of kind of historian
she agreed with me
she agreed with me but she didn't get
the venom that i got she literally said
muhammad dilly has made the right point
churchill has blood on his hands he did
the bengal famine he's not free of war
crimes he had very repulsive and racist
views i just said the same thing
like
how are you not lynching me on tv and
then allowing next month to just get
away with it
um
and let her you know just giving her an
easy ride which by the way has support i
appreciated i needed that support
because i also use that to show the
double consistency and that's
secular liberals for you bro that's
secular liberals for you and there's a
spectrum of it and the reason why that
is is unfortunately these are people who
are inconsistent because their beliefs
are inconsistent
their goal posts are constantly shifting
why because they have made their nafs
good
they've taken their desires as gods
the desire of men and and a particular
group of men and a particular type of
men in a particular
looking and socio-economic status of men
you know essentially dictate what the
rules will be of a given society the
fact that 30 years ago in the uk that
you know same-sex marriage and
homosexual acts was a crime and could
you could be jailed if you were found to
be persistent on it then it was
something that was just findable then it
was something that was told to do in
private then ten years later you can now
marry now you can't say nothing you get
down for hate speech so the moral gold
posts are constantly shifting you want
to accuse so western states commonly
accuse our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi who are selling the most best of
creation to have walked this earth you
accuse him of horrible things with
regards to the marriage
but let me say something to you all
why is there an inconsistency in your
age of consent
why is it 14 in spain why is he 16 in
britain why can a 12 year old legally
get married in texas
who are you not to talk to us about
consistency shut up move on jog on don't
talk to us about this and that we have
clear guidance alhamdulillah we have
clear guidance and it's because you
don't abandon your guidance that the
messenger of islam came as the final
message and of course people who take
this when you make your nafs the source
the sharia of your law bonn it man
you're gonna have all kinds of
inconsistencies pierce morgan
by the way is there is a syrian
entertainer and troll but at the same
time look like for example his beef with
harry's misses kate yeah
it's got nothing it's just that she
blanked him she blanked him at a party
she never gave him the respect that she
wanted and he fancied her that's the
truth
that is pierce morgan's beef with kate
uh not kate yeah what's her name harry's
wife thing uh uh
megan yeah megan that's his beef with
megan he's beefing megan was he met her
once she never really acknowledged him
again at another public gathering so he
felt embarrassed and that he fancied her
and that's his beef yeah so similarly
pierce morgan having a pop-up me whilst
not having to pop up the exact of a
christian white vicar for holding the
same views it doesn't surprise me in the
same way that when i was on bbc sunday
morning live debating uh dresden and and
and british history where they should be
glorified i was getting slated and
lynched upon whilst the white oxford
professor said the same thing actually
defended me on tv she didn't get slated
so it should it's not something that
should surprise us by the way it should
be something that surprises because if
we look at
quraish
and how they dealt with the muslims in
the early years of makkah
first it was about you know
um
give muhammad and his people
who ascended talk to them you know try
like
diplomacy let's talk to them let's go
for abu talib and others to say look and
second your message down man when that
didn't work what did they resort to
names and labels he's a he's a madman
he's a magician he's someone who's
cursed he's the one who splits
households that didn't work then what
happened persecution so we know this
this is the sunnah of the four anyway
it is the sunnah of the fall to be
inconsistent and to be so losers and
non-muslims who watch this podcast this
is not towards all non-muslims we are
talking about your rulers your elite
your regime your governments your states
your policy makers your movers and
shakers
and this is why when islam came to those
lands which were christian they came to
islam in their droves and many of them
stayed christian and they lived
prosperously under the sharia
[Music]
give me comfort to know that left will
always be left and right will always be
right falsehood will always be falsehood
truth will always be truth
you know we don't care what the west
wants to portray
they have this undeniable i guess fetish
with showing that islam is losing when
in reality bro the amount of rebirths
every single day bro they're not going
to show that but when one i guess woman
uh from let's say uh lebanon you know um
i'm just saying these countries
arbitrarily guys don't don't think i
have anything against y'all let's say
publicly leaves islam they're going to
sensationalize the crap out of this bro
of course look i once you know when you
look at the oig situation right
and you think to yourself that there is
believed to be at least two million of
our brothers and sisters in
concentration camps as we speak
i say this
if these one well if these one are
people of kalima and taqwan iman the
chinese regime wouldn't need
concentration camps the very fact that
they're holding on to their islam
is the reason why this concentration
counts
the very fact that there are successive
governments left and right center left
center right this that successive all
across the west all have one thing in
common
in their laws and discrimination against
the muslims
their laws and discrimination against
the muslims from the prison of counters
counter terrorism
and they don't differ in that and why do
they why do they need that they need
that because they're seeing that muslims
have become practicing
we're having opposite effect
we thought these that would assimilate
like other groups we thought they'd
assimilate like christians or like sri
lankan or indian hindus or like chinese
atheists or like you know uh caribbean
or west indian christians nah
nah
and they're really like third fourth
generation muslims in the west diaspora
are actually more religious than their
forefathers that came as economic
migrants it burns them the highest
number of rebirths in europe are white
women
white european women of course they're
going to burn us they want to eat
they want to distinguish the light of
allah it's not going to happen that's
fine bro right when you said
white women from the uk subhanallah you
guys think he's making this up as soon
as he said that look at this sister
jillian smith writes i'm a new muslim
muslim named khadija i'm a white and
blind from the uk i have lived in
pakistan and long to go back there the
west is haram and i'm sure the trumpet
is going to blow very soon proof is in
the pudding man you can't make this up
i was with aira me hanzo zolces we all
worked together i was the head of
department i was the head of media and
public relations for two years
and i'm telling you the highest number
of reverse
are why english money
the highest number of conversions
yeah and they come and they and they
hold on to the deen with dear life now
allah bless them preserve them may they
be the mothers of the future princes and
rulers of this of this of this continent
who like who will inshallah rule of the
justice of islam inshallah they would be
the women who will
will have the children that will come on
to rule this with this content i believe
this i believe with so many white
sisters
white women accepted white european
women accepting islam i believe that
this is not based on nothing it's just
something which i feel will happen that
you know because if you think about it
there were 36 ottoman sultans of
khulafar the vast majority
of their mothers were white slaves were
white concubines
do you understand and and many of the
ottoman
sultan were white they were caucasian
that slavic that that anything but turks
in them do you understand because their
mothers were european women i believe
similarly not making that comparison by
the way from today's sister just want to
clarify that today's sisters who are
white european under concubine no what
i'm saying is that i believe that white
female muslim converse reavers whatever
you want to call it
will have a special role to play in this
continent
[Music]
so um with that being said are there any
other things that you want to get off in
this theme that we had for the podcast
today if not we can start the q a insha
allah so just three points i want to
make because obviously the conversation
was about
essentially global politics in light of
ukraine and russia
and the inconsistency of secular
liberalism is odd and advocates and so
forth and generally just some things
pertaining to islam and muslims is
revival first and foremost the ukraine
and russia conflict i will reiterate for
those of us who are not living directly
in those affected areas
there is no there's
there's no necessity for us to take a
position
in the same way that if an invading army
came to the british shores it is not on
the muslims of india to tell us who to
take sides because they've come to my
doorstep now i might have to make a
choice
so similarly it is on those muslims of
those regions who are already conflicted
is on them to make a call and make a
decision we just pray to allah
that allah protects the innocent
civilians and the muslims of that region
from the oppression and violence of both
sides i mean
second point
second point about
the inconsistencies of secular secular
liberals and its artists and its
advocates and so forth in the media
governments parties brothers and sisters
being a muslim was never supposed to be
easy
yeah allah says in the quran
do you believe that you will not be
tested in your faith
allah is telling us we will be testing
in our faith
that it's not going to be an easy ride
how dare we claim to be the torchbearers
and the flag bearers of the only
exclusive truth
yeah and not be expected and then not
expect to have some heat on us
do we not know the hadith
that there will come a time where
holding on to islam will be
like holding onto a hot coal that islam
came strange and it will come back
strange so give black tiding to the
strangers we know these things allah
tells us he has set out the paradigm the
quranic paradigm is this
imam
belief as disbelief good versus evil
that's it and we are in the camp of good
we're in the camp of imam and islam and
so therefore when we look at the stories
of the lives of the prophets
with exception
with exception to
uh
without the older era of islam
all the prophets that we are aware of
all the all the ambiya that we are aware
of including the prophet sallam
faced oppression and opposition from
their people
i wanted to add a quick point that a lot
of people think just like you said allah
subhanahu wa in the quran rights do they
think they'll say i believe and they
won't be tested right so
you know you you you really look at you
really look at the state of the prophet
ibrahim
and we see their lives you know the
prophet saw some lost all of his
children except one
lost his wife
early you know compared to when when his
time was near
uh lost his father-in-law lost loved
ones right was born without a father so
you look at all of these trials and
tribulations that the prophet the
messenger of allah
what makes you think you're immune as
just an average joe as just a layman as
just tom dick and harry today you know
just barely making your salah you know
or even if you're if you're on it on it
nowhere are we near the prophet
and look at the the hardships that he
had so when when i really put that into
perspective i was like bro why do i
expect things to be easy for me
let alone easier than him subhanallah
well just from that point because it's
important that we take these lessons
right
we know that when the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he approached waraka no
full right and told him about
uh i think it was up in norfolk
um uncle i'm not sure it was one of the
two it could be the same person but
either way when he when he
told him about the revelation he had
received for the first time from
jubrilla
what did he say to the prophet
he said this is a call where your people
will turn against you and they will
drive you out of your out of your town
and you're on your area and the price of
someone was shocked he's like well
what my people but they're going to
drive me why they believe me to be the
most
the most truthful and what happened we
know about the hadith
because we are suffering and the prophet
said in poland our people were tested
before them
so we know that ibrahimovic protests
[Music]
is like a blueprint he's the most
mentioned in the quran for a reason he
lived bani israel so the seas split
and they worship the cow
how was he tested by his people
his latter you know the way bani israel
you know tested muslim is so sad
they all were opposed by their people
they were tested by their people whether
it is by their people from a believing
point of view which doesn't apply to the
prophet sallam or by general
right they were always opposed oppressed
so what makes you think that we're going
to have an easy ride we're not and
secular liberals and all these other
isms and liberals and all that spectrum
faith
just just brace embrace yourself for
inconsistencies brace yourself for
double standards and hypocrites don't be
surprised
foolish is the one that expects
consistency from them
oof i was literally just going to say
this as soon as you said don't expect it
i was going to say if anything expect
you know that if it is consistent that
there's something wrong with that you
know that should you know alarm bells
should be ringing
and i think the third i think the third
point my brother was on just the issue
of islamic revival yeah and i'm going to
make it very quick today marks the 98th
gregorian year since the abolition of
the caliphate
for all for all intents and purposes for
good bad and ugly this was a noble
institution that was left to us by
rasulallah
and by abu bakr and uman and ali and
hassan
classical spoke about its normative
basis
there have been
throughout centuries that have said that
the establishment of the religion is
incomplete and impossible without this
institution
so i will say to you brothers and
sisters for good bad or ugly for all
intents and purposes no one's saying
it's a romanticized utopian society no
one ever claims that and anyone who
claims that
as muslims please don't do that but what
we will say is this
that when islam had a civilization
when islam had a central authority or
central authorities
when we had rulers irrespective whether
were tyrants or not but had the fear of
allah in terms of ruling by islam
things were very different and as rami
said it was only less than 100 years ago
right and even at his most weakest time
even right at his weakest time when the
ottoman
used to send warning shots to the
europeans they used to take heed
they used to take him and that was at
the most weakest time
so what i will say is that the victory
of allah
is not a matter of if it is a matter of
when
now you decide where you fit into that
timeline do you want to be a bystander
or do you want to be a contributor to
this revival and this victory in
whatever capacity you can contribute
that is my message to the brothers and
sisters you tuned into this man i
couldn't have even said it better bro
that was a wonderful point to wrap up
everything in this stream on insha allah
so uh we'll go with the the q and now
whenever it's approaching time for
maghrib inshallah for you let me know
and we'll quickly wrap it up in sha
allah
25 minutes if you want me
25 minutes
okay so first question oh i really
appreciate it okay let's answer your
question
cool next so um
when you mention the us as being the
world police
would western sanctions on russia be a
good example do you think russia would
respond irrationally with nuclear
strikes
what i said earlier on in the podcast
was that the usa is one of five
policemen of the world and they are
definitely the most biggest powerful of
the policemen
western sanctions against russia
is a double-edged sword so all this
conversation about banning them from
swift uh banking systems and so forth
they have equally said that these are
going to affect our businesses as well
domestically because we're heavily
reliant on trade with russia right
do i believe
and by the way did you know that putin
about four months before the invasion of
ukraine he managed to get hold of 6.4
billion
cash because he anticipated sanctions
so
so just on the cash flow he thought okay
they're going to bring the heat on let's
just have a bit of a bit of a you know
secret stash to hold on until that time
comes yeah
so the point is western sanctions
will hurt russia it is hurting russia
it's hurting many ordinary russians but
the point of the mayor is that it's not
as if russia doesn't have any aces up
his sleeve and that's namely its natural
gas yeah
now would that lead to russia starting a
nuclear war respectfully no
no because
quite frankly there's enough nuclear
weapons between russia and america to
blow this world over 80 or 100 times
we've still got the day of judgment and
the major signs of the day of judgement
coming and none of that really explains
about nuclear warheads we've got so many
things to happen so let's everyone relax
here yeah
we are muslims who believe in the day of
judgement and we've been told what those
major major 10 signs are
and none of them really include a
nuclear war between america and russia
yes there's going to be some end of time
wars that'll be the coming of isa
the more kind of normative mainstream
position because i know there's like a
technicality of differences
these are not metaphors brothers and
sisters a lot of people are like yeah
jews and mountains are like
liberals
like the mainstream normative suddenly
positioned on these things that i've
just mentioned is literal yeah
so
none of that includes really a nuclear
war that if it happens and i'm basing
this if on a hypothetical situation
nuclear war would literally mean the
world's finish because that's what
nuclear weapons are
and they've got enough nuclear weapons
to destroy
the entire world over but i say this
i'm not ruling out the possibility
of a nuclear attack
that would change and radically shift
the balance of power
in the world
to somehow favor the muslims
i'm not ruling that out
okay
next question
uh
does ukraine have missiles which you can
use to
bomb russian territory
um
not to the kind of sophisticated levels
that it would like
um it does have kind of very basic uh
ballistic very like low level type
missile not great ranges if they went to
the
if ukraine if ukraine had access to its
western buddha
right then i'm sure it would be able to
have missiles that would be but not
missiles in the sense like
uh like western superpowers have so that
so the longshore answers that is no
they have they have armory and weaponry
that could reach russia but not as
sophisticated on the level which would
cause any meaningful damage to russia
um okay
writes what was imran khan doing in
russia does anyone know
i think uh i think the connection is
suffering right now
can you hear me brother
so sister khadija writes what was imran
khan doing in russia does anyone know
it might be it might be connection mind
fire let me just move to another room
okay okay no worries noise
so what's the next question there's one
about what was pakistan doing in russia
yeah what was it doing in russia
trying to make a deal
pakistan's economy is entirely he needs
to make deal with everyone he can its
position is already very close to china
as a result of cpec and so forth and
obviously china is playing a very
interesting role in this uh many people
are saying that has there been a secret
deal struck between russia and china
which emboldened russia to do it and
that in light of sanctions
china would support it financially and
not allow its economy to
uh basically uh break down and pakistan
you know what pakistan is one of those
countries
obviously bangladesh is obviously
it's it's a bit of a marmite marmite
situation isn't it yeah but but i am of
the position first and foremost we can
never hold
all pakistanis
for the crimes of a group of people
policymakers that did what they did
yeah
but it is a country that has huge
potential it is the only muslim country
that has nuclear weapons
till this day i cannot fathom why
pakistan with its resources
with i i don't believe pakistan has
truly discovered its aspirations
its depth and its potential
it is like it is like the big muscle
it's like the thick bully it's like the
thick muscle of the playground that gets
used
it gets used
saudi will saudi will call upon pakistan
when it needs help
america will come and do what it needs
to do
but pakistan itself
is a great big country that can do a lot
for islam and muslims i believe this but
it hasn't found its potential and its
aspiration and why because the sis
is what's the isi
and the military establishment they are
split between three camps
the nationalists the pro-americans and
the islamists the islamists are the
weakest so the islamists are kind of
like they're popular on a grassroots
low-ranking army level
but but the nationalists they move
between the islamists and the
pro-americans and the prime minister
yeah but the pro-americans are the ones
that receive the military aid they're
the ones that receive most of the money
and backing and power so really it is
upon the muslims of pakistan to rectify
their affairs insha'allah to then try
lead by example yeah because it has the
potential but it doesn't understand its
own potential that's what that's why
imran khan is literally going around and
has been since his tenure with a begging
bull for handouts and help
from other countries
um i agree before i go on with the
questions i had one question from uh to
you as a fellow bengali do you notice
this a lot or is it just me bro in the
bengali community and the whole desi
community that they have this whole the
white man is the savior you know like
they still have that slave mindset bro
that if we don't know english well that
if we're not fair and lovely in terms of
our skin complexion if we don't get
approval from them if we don't get
validation from them we're nobody you
know
yes that exists but i think we have to
be fair here for you i'll tell you why
bro yeah
when leading nations
like super powers are leading
civilizations
people always want to imitate the
leading nations and civilizations that's
that's just the way it is the very fact
that the way you are dressed the way you
are and i am dressed the way i am is the
fact that whether we like it or not bro
we've accepted that as a particular
style of
a particular look which is seen as cool
and the best and people look upon
westerners like yeah we want to speak at
them
in the same way that the crusaders when
they came back they came back doing
arabic poetry
and they came back dressing like arabs
and some of the christians in europe say
look at these or we sent them to to
bring the holy land back and they've
come back freaking speaking arabic
poetry
right you understand so people lesser
nations will always try to imitate the
more powerful nations had there not been
the crusades there would not have been
the renaissance the renaissance happened
because those christians and europeans
that went to the crusades in the muslim
world bought and learned things from the
muslims which led to the renaissance
which then that's the enlightenment
which then there to the industrial
revolution and the age of european
colonialism another super simplification
and that's a super simplification but
that is what happened so
we shouldn't be surprised my brother
we shouldn't be surprised that we want
to imitate the god that we want to
imitate the white european the westerner
that shouldn't surprise that because
there was a time where people wanted to
imitate the muslims they wanted to
imitate the andalusians they wanted to
imitate the ottomans they wanted to
imitate you understand so so that's i'm
not surprised by that and then obviously
there was the brutalization of
colonialism right which then gave us the
the kind of
they basically taught us what is good
and bad what's nice and not nice what's
attractive or not what's beautiful or
not they imprinted they imprinted it
generations ago and it's it's deeper
of course so
the answer to your question is yes it
still very much exists but all i'm
saying is let's have a bit of husu
in terms of the context of why it is
like that our job is to turn that around
our job is to change that our job is to
highlight to them that are you trying to
please allah azzawajal or are you trying
to please this law why are you trying to
imitate that how far are you going to go
in imitating them how far are you going
to go in imitating them so yes the
answer to your question is yes it exists
it very much exists but i think slowly
inshallah is things are changing
because because the the the winds of
revivals here bro man the winds of
revivals here bro um
my older siblings speak
i just about speak facility
but the fact that you said enough to say
that so there is the lingua franco in
bangladesh
it's pretty similar of course it is it's
a dialect but it is a strong action no i
need to say something because there
might be some facility usability here
yeah silet sileti is regarded as his own
language with his own alphabet not that
i can lose sleep over this but it is a
thing and then it just kind of got
harmonized as a dialect as part of
sheikh mujib's uh attempt at unifying
the bengali language uh under the new
state
by bangladesh
so just taken for half of my life for
for the second half of my life i have
never been back to the homeland
i said number this but i could
understand why first and foremost
i'm 10 years your senior
right secondly you're from canada so
there is a longer distance did you know
this by the way when i was in vancouver
i was in vancouver in 2020
and my daddy passed away may allah have
mercy on her i mean when i was out in
canada
vancouver
to bangladesh or vancouver
to okay vancouver edmonton whichever but
west canada to bangladesh is the
equivalent of
britain to australia meaning 24 hours
yeah it's diametrically opposed yeah
yeah yeah yeah because i realized i'm
like i'm speaking to my mom it's like
the same time but a complete day ahead
and i'm like whoa and then i realized so
what i will encourage you my brother is
when you get an opportunity go my
brother because
it's our roots
it's our roots and at the end of the day
if we ever get kicked out of these
countries for whatever we do
pakistanis and bengalis even something
like making sure that you eat rice and
curry at home once or twice a week
ensuring that you have that chapatis is
something that instills within your
children and the family that there is
there is there is something else that
defines us and so and because
bangladeshi bangladeshi culture and
heritage is mainly predominantly muslim
and islamic i don't care what anyone
says i don't care what the league says
the the the the bulk of our the bulk of
our heritage is islamic so
things like speaking the language eating
the food these kind of like cultural
things is important because at a time
we're increasingly losing those kind of
identities it's important because
bangladesh is a muslim majority country
and so therefore is somewhat to some
degree to some degree our culture is
heavily influenced by islam even though
there's a lot of hindu influences as
well yeah the point is but the point is
we do
i do encourage brothers to go
bro you just motivated me now i'm just
gonna buy uh the next flight to dhaka
inshallah and then tell me tell me maybe
we can go together bro inshallah let's
make it happen bro let's make it happen
bro
brother jay perez writes can dilly
mention where and how to contact him and
recommend readings or resources so i
believe brother de liusen mentioned that
he's going to send it to me and i'll
just put it over here but is anywhere
that they can you know contact you guys
or five pillars
of course so you can you can catch us on
all our socials but if you want to
contact me uh instagram daily.hussein88
twitter
dailyhusein88 um facebook you'll find me
you can you can contact us on info
firepillersuk.com
and yeah just a shout out
because the brother uh perez who asked
earlier he asked books for so many
different subjects
so what i'll do is i'll just send you
some books which you can post on the
comments inshallah or maybe address him
directly uh and share it then because
it's quite funny there's too many books
so i'll suggest some
i'll
share it with you
all right sister sen's brother do you
think we can go back to the islamic
golden age or do we have to wait for the
mahdi
you think we can go back to the islamic
golden age let me address that one first
first and foremost actually let me ask
you something
you know we commonly hear about the
islamic golden age
yeah they tend to refer to andalus
uh
baghdad under the abbasids right
um the the period of intellectual uh
mathematical uh uh
you know geometrical whatever they're
all that kind of advancement yeah
but the actual golden
era golden period of islam
were the first three generations
i was going to ask you the question but
i've answered it for you
the the actual golden era of islam
were the first three generations of
islam the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and his companions
the prophet sallallahu alaihi sallam
said that they were the best of
generations so therefore we measure our
golden age based on that because they
ruled according to islam the most
closest and the most perfect in those
generations that is our golden era
golden age that's the golden age that we
want to you know repeat and bring back
and inshallah improve as for this golden
age of science and geometry and maths
and technology advancement look who even
who even
created this term golden age and
associated to those things europeans did
we did it it's a popular term that they
gave and we're just going with it
look into our books look into our books
of history and finally where a reputable
sunni scholar says that this is the
golden era of islam because we did x y
and z no the golden era of islam is the
first three generations
right so we so now we're being told what
our golden generation is do you
understand how our golden era is how
dare you shut up what are you talking
about you don't tell us whatever say it
then say that say that the era of
advancement
was this period but do not say that
islam's golden era were those periods
because in those same periods we had
princes and sultans that
weren't so islamic
and they were getting up to all kinds of
shenanigans right during this kind of
enlightenment period the reason why
islam alhamdulillah for over a millennia
uh allows such advancements right in in
in in in you know maths and science and
technology and stuff like this
it's because there was never a conflict
between this because allah tells us that
you know look at the alteration of night
and day surely these are signs of men of
understanding allah tells us
continuously
think question that's fine we we never
had a problem with science and the human
intellect because we were that confident
that's europe's problem that's europe's
problem don't impose
your issues with the with the pope and
the vatican to us you lot had the
problem where your bible wasn't even
translated into your respective
languages until bloody king james came
and did in the 1600s
don't come to us and tell us about our
golden age when you wouldn't even allow
women to basically read the bible in
fact the normal the lay christian in
europe for a thousand years could not
access the bible
do you understand so what you're on
yeah don't come and superimpose those
problems that you not had in europe to
us islam never had that problem islam's
decline happened when we moved away from
islam that's when our decline happened
yeah
your last revival happened when you
moved away from the oppressive nature of
christianity
and that's and that's that's good on you
man but don't don't apply that to us
we never had the conflict between
science and the intellect of man and
questioning and reason and these kind of
things
don't try
most of the jean-jacques russo and all
these nightmare fingers would they
praise they praise ghazali the praise
i've ever seen that they praise our
people
yeah so we never had these problems you
lot had these problems you don't have to
have bloody wars to overthrow kings and
kingdoms to then somehow access the
bible and then like create different
variations of your religion which is
more liberal and more open to free
thought we never had those problems we
never had that dogma between science and
our religious tradition we never did
brothers and sisters when someone says
to you the golden era of islam
respectfully correct those non-muslims
say it is the golden era from the
perspective of these specific
advancements by our actual golden era
with the first three generations why
because they were most they were the
most closest to islam they were the most
closest to the prophet they were the
most closest to the revelation
um
alhamdulillah man that was spot on
okay
made of earth rights fired comment first
you may not like it aesthetically
bro see i was born in bangladesh right
and i lived there for the first four or
five years of my life so i'm very
friendly and i've been there
many times after that you know it's just
bro studying medicine in canada it's
such a long process you got to go with
the undergrad then you got to go to med
right so total it's like 89 years for me
bro i'm like seven years deep and this
is after high school you know so i have
two two more years left insha allah make
dua for me and when it's done inshallah
but it's it's not that i don't want to
go it's just i know this sounds crazy
but i just haven't gone around to it and
it just happened to have been 12 years
bro
i'm trying to make you successful in
your in your studies my brother and in
your worldly affairs to give you the
best outcome of janna and the hereafter
i mean um look we all have priorities in
it we have priorities and sometimes if
you're studying to that level inside
depth sometimes a visit to bangladesh
isn't a priority but i tell you
something though yeah every time i go
bangladesh and i've been in 99 i've been
in 2012.
no no 99 i went
2005 i went
uh
2012 i went and then obviously 2020 i
went yeah
every time i've been it all is like i
don't know where you're from
like are you i'm
okay so facilities are mainly if not
entirely from like we're from a little
bit from the kind of rural areas right
yeah and ev every time i go bangladesh
bro yeah my what my my western privilege
uh comes out and i start kicking out it
always takes me two three days to adjust
it always takes me 2-3 days to adjust
i'm kicking off no microwave not running
hot water bloody mosquitoes you know i
mean yeah you know i always go and then
after two three days
i'm like okay cool i think i'm listening
to it it's just blessed but but those
two first two three days no matter how
many times i've visited i always need to
adjust because i'm not used to it it
takes outside of your comfort zone you
understand but i love it i love it
because it tests me it reminds me how
privileged we actually are in the sense
that we're quite british and devious
you know i mean we take things for
granted as soon as we go to the kind of
rural areas and very developing world we
start understanding okay this is how
people live and it it always shocks me i
know what i'm expecting but it always
shocks me um so i encourage you my bro
when the time is right go if you want to
go together let's do it let's make it
happen bro insha allah um one thing is
like you notice these things too like
you saying these things are bringing
back memories you know you go there's no
more you know i want to wear this fit
tomorrow and it's dirty so let me just
you know put it in the washer and put in
the dryer it's going to take like 24
minimum hours for it to hang dry outside
you know
it really humbles me man 100 but so then
something says so it's like little
little things like no running hot water
right so we have to boil water or hope
that the sun heats the tanky which would
give us hot water yeah
yeah then obviously my people there as
in my relatives there then they're not a
washing machine they'll go wash it in
the [ __ ] they'll go wash it in the
with some with some soap and stuff and
then they'll dry out and the clothes are
fine bro um you know if if my people say
to me if my family say to me food's
ready i need to go and eat because
there's no microwave i need to go wash
the food as well to understand now
obviously there are more there has been
immense modernization in bangladesh
bangladesh has one of the fastest
growing economies in asia with one of
the highest gdps comparatively to many
uh asian countries but i will still say
that that benefits only a group of
people
those those things those things
really benefit a group of people that
average bangladeshi sadly like in
pakistan and in india and in indonesia
sadly are living below poverty beyond
comprehension in the west beyond
comprehension the west so whilst yes
bangladesh is one of the fastest growing
economies
things are happening
it will always benefit the middle class
the upper middle class and the elite not
the average bangladeshi whether they're
in chittagong or raj shahi or kamilah or
dhaka or cinema
facilities are a bit facilities are a
bit different though you have to
understand because cities have the
largest diaspora community outside of
bangladesh in the west namely the uk so
a lot of british money has been pumped
into sinner and so
yeah so the living standards facilities
and there's always a saying i know it's
not a nice thing but they say even the
beggars in cilic want want pounds yeah
they say that even even the beggars in
cilic want pounds because they're used
to big bucks
and big money yeah because because
they're used to brits coming and
spending and investing in cilic
how big is the muscle population there
bro just as the brothers are asking i'll
wait for this to come so you may be
surprised brothers and sisters right you
may be surprised when we talk about the
ummah the ummah
40 of the ummah is in pakistan india
bangladesh and indonesia how about that
how about that
that one in five muslims if not two in
five will be from those four countries
if we remove the colonial borders of
pakistan and bangladesh and they see it
as hind yeah
bro the vast majority of the umma are
from hind
yeah and from and if you put indonesia
into that then you're looking at
basically 40 of the global umma are from
those four countries so bangladesh is
bangladesh's muslim population as it
stands and obviously we don't have kind
of thorough you know comprehensive
research but the kind of rough number is
160 million muslims but i want to say
something about this
that's 160 million muslims in a country
that fits
five and a half times in pakistan
and over 12 times in bang in india
put that into perspective now
pakistan has 210 million
bangladesh is 160 but it is four and a
half times or five and a half times
smaller
for brother dilly
what's the time now it's 5 47 is
[ __ ]
okay yeah so yeah i'll take one more
question if you want it now inshallah
there's no question we'll write uh we'll
just pull one of these comments this is
from sister wide um she's the one that
handles our tick tock masha'allah so she
writes the regression of the islamic
world back to jahilya happened as a
result of the muslim world abandoning
real islamic principles and adopting
culture over thee
there is truth to this there's truth to
this because look the decline of the
islamic civilization which would
prophesize in the
very
uh well known hadith
to shorten it the prophet sallallahu
islam already told us that after
prophethood there will be
then there will be
kings
then there will be a biting tyranny then
there will be
and then it will return upon the
methodology of prophethood and the
rasulullah stayed quiet
many of the scholars took from this
sahih hadith that him staying quiet
means
that when it comes it is
it will stay until the day of judgment
some scholars have taken it from that
and this is linked to a question that
someone else asked about do we wait for
imam
it is not the position of ah sunnah to
say that
would be established when imam mahdi
comes
we say that because the the few
narrations that we do have about imam
mahdi is that he will come at a time
where there will be wars between or a
dispute between the three sons of the
kulafa
so there will already be
establishment whether is weak or corrupt
or big or small it doesn't matter that
that
authentic narration says that when imam
arrives there will be a feud a dispute
between the sons of the khalifah who's
died and then they will the people will
choose him
yeah so it is not from you know this
nihilistic lazy understanding that we're
going to wait for imam mahdi
to wait for imam
are you okay
we'll see how how much you're willing
when something comes to your doorstep no
no we are not a people who say we wait
for imam mahdi we say that imam he will
come and he will rule by justice just as
we were told and he is from the noble
lineage of rasulallah that's what we say
about imam
we do not say that he will come and
establish
it so it's not a victim mindset yeah we
say that he will come and he will
probably find a killer established and
he will insha allah take it to levels
that it needs to be taken that's what
needs to be said uh and just on that
sister's point before i before i part
is that
what happens is that when we've had
rulers and states and polities and
sultanates and caliphates for 1400 years
you know there's been many instances
where the raw desire and passion and
zeal and understanding the obligation of
spreading the word of allah to the four
corners of the earth that when men
started becoming attached to dunya
things and decide fighting each other
that allah prepared us for defeat and
decline
do you understand he did he he got us
ready for defeat and declined that's
what happens
when we become a generation that is not
worthy of allah's victory and
establishment on earth allah will remove
us and replace us with another people so
if you want to be of that camp
which is i'm going to wait for imam
mahdi you're going to get replaced
swiftly and you won't even be a footnote
in history so you brothers and sisters
who believe in this please change this
mindset change this mindset
yeah because we are a people who believe
in the
of course we believe the entirety of the
quran but we commonly say that allah
tell us in surah al-imran we have raised
you from amongst
we have raised you as the best nation
from amongst mankind
allah did not stop there he caveated
that by saying why because we're
enjoining good and forbid evil and
believe in allah
yeah we know of the hadith of the
prophet salallahu said that when you see
believers he's a monker an evil he try
he should change you with his hands
and if you can't you should speak out
against it if then the lowest of iman is
to hate it from within that's what a
muslim is
a muslim is someone who invites to allah
does good and says i am one of the
muslims
again a verse from the quran yeah
so this is the mindset of a muslim the
mindset of a muslim isn't i'm gonna wait
for imam that's when things will be sued
no no no no that is unprophetic and i
would even got something on islamic
i feel like people don't know that they
lack that understanding of that
perspective that you just shared with us
bro because it's the i don't want to say
this in in equal and measure but
figuratively right it's the equivalent
of people saying oh if my colors already
written why do anything it's like no bro
allah knows what you're going to do but
you still got to do it you know 100
there's a sphere that we control and
there's a sphere that we don't control
the sphere that we control is what we're
going to be accounted for do you
understand so so we can't have that and
you know we have lots of muslims sadly
and worryingly adopting kind of like uh
liberal left kind of like liberal left
kind of social justice kind of like
mindsets right the entire concept of
social justice all came from islam islam
has an entire corpus of of how to tackle
injustice and oppression that's what
allah he puts the moon upon the highest
ranking of evildoers on earth we have a
blueprint to address oppression and
injustice do not fall into this mindset
of our imam is going to come fixed with
our problems that is like the one who
said that my father's caused the
problems and my sons will will fix the
problem where do you fit into this where
do you fit into that then if the
problems were caused by your forefathers
and you're hoping your children are
going to saw it you're just a waste man
and you're not looking to do anything so
brothers and sisters fix up that mindset
move away from it we are a people of
taqwa and iman and action yeah that's
what we are we are not people who sit
back and relax and think yeah you know
what imam matthew will come sort it out
we're not about that life
um
subhanallah bro what a wonderful point
to end it on bro it really puts into
perspective that a lot of us are in that
middle bridge you know we are that
middle generation where we are trying to
advance and and try to even
almost advise and guide our forefathers
in the right path but we also have this
immense responsibility that we have to
be responsible for the next generation
inshallah and may allah equip us and our
family and our loved ones and all of us
to fight the right battles withhold
things that are not necessary
and have the discernment to know what is
what insha allah i mean
i want to say one quick thing before i
go here go for it
brothers and sisters
the muslims of this generation i.e the
last
80 years
but specifically our generation
we are a generation that
i believe muslims in the future in years
to come will study
intricately
and they will see how we dealt with the
struggles that we've had
because never in islamic history
never since the message of islam came to
the people of arabia under under the
prophet sallam from when the khilafah
was abolished in 1924 even though it was
weakened and somewhat
you know it wasn't doing much for
for many years but the point is when
that got taken away
and what we have faced and experienced
whether it's the centuries of brutal
colonialism the ideological warfare
between normative islam to change what
we believe to water it down to
secularize us all of this stuff
we're experiencing
others have not experienced it like that
in the past
yes they had the mongol invasion yes
they had other things but i truly
believe
that the generation of muslims in the
last 80 years and for coming decades is
going to be a special golden generation
because insha allah we will be that
generation that brings victory to islam
why why
because
we
have been in a situa situation where our
forefathers and our predecessors have
never had a situation like this
yes the mongols came yes the mongols
came they ravaged our lands but after a
hundred years they became muslim the
mongols became muslim
and we regained those lands but the
point is the situation now is like none
other in our history and you know what
that means that means it's time for ajah
it's time to be history makers
don't be a bystander brothers and
sisters
don't be don't be bisexual we're living
a special generation man i truly believe
that those who are active for the dean
of islam now
yeah
that we're going to have a special
status inshallah if our deeds and our
efforts are accepted i genuinely believe
that we will have a special status in
the history of islam as that generation
that had to deal with external threats
internal threats and everything else in
the absence of a central authority in
the absence of any meaningful governance
or rulership that will protect the
israel and the life of the blood of the
muslims
never have we been in such a state where
we have been oppressed and colonized and
brutalized and i believe it's only gonna
get worse before allah's victory comes
and i believe it's gonna be this
generation because the generations
before did not experience this and we
pray to allah we rectify it before our
future generations we have a special
status is now your choice whether you
want to be a contributor or a bystander
on the day of judgment
i mean
with that being said man
i really regret that
brother angel and ramy were here because
this was such a you know real
live vibe but insha allah is not the
first this is the first of many insha
allah and man stay tuned for anyone
watching um i have a channel too where i
vlog so inshallah bangladesh vlog
featuring brother dilly hussain 100. and
i'm serious about the fight once you're
ready my bro once we're ready let's just
liaise with each other and we'll go dash
together inshallah you show me dakar and
i'll show you silly bro inshallah i'm
done i've never been a celeb bro let's
make it happen
all right
with that being said if you guys made it
this far smash the like button brother
hussein if people want to connect with
you or follow your socials where should
they find you at so literally instagram
diddy.hussein88 you'll find me that uh
twitter daily hussein 88 and just dilly
hussein and you'll find us everyone five
pillars news you just have to google it
so nothing complex nothing tricky just
need to google or find me on delhi
hussein aea or five pillars and all our
platforms and our socials will come up
inshaallah insha allah
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
you